como están
bueno principalmente quería decirles que
soy dentro de este multiculturalismo soy
un amante de la tecnología o sea estamos
los programadores también que como que
no tenemos mucho de que es abocarnos
sino que amamos la programación o sea
nuestro principal como lo que tenemos
allá arriba es hacer que las
computadoras nos entiendan o que hagan
lo que nosotros queremos que hagan si
las tecnologías me encantan me encanta
la tecnología y desde muy chico me
gustaba la robótica cuando era chico y
fui un espectador de que en esta época
desde que yo estoy vivo hubo una
revolución tecnológica importantísima o
sea si ustedes se ponen a pensar como
cómo ha cambiado todo desde que nosotros
empezábamos con las computadoras cuando
yo era chico la computadora no tenía el
sistema operativo se había que meter un
disquete para que ande y actualmente se
hacen un montón de cosas con las
computadoras tienen un poder de
procesamiento increíble internet
internet no existía yo no podré cuando
era chico internet no existía y ahora es
como que no podría estar sin internet
tampoco ustedes las cosas caras los
teléfonos celulares tampoco o sea yo
tenía un teléfono fijo que tenía que
llamar el al del vecino encima tenía que
llamar a alguien tenía que cruzar me la
verdad llamaba a alguien y ahora tengo
un celular y en esa época como un
espectador de los cambios tecnológicos
yo veía que podía llegar a venir toda
esta tecnología ya vislumbraba que era
necesario tener teléfonos que pudiéramos
en cualquier momento llamar a alguien
que pudiéramos comunicarnos con
cualquier persona en cualquier momento y
era algo que nosotros los que estábamos
en la parte tecnológica veíamos como
necesario y no puedo creer que se haya
dado tan rápido si una de las cosas por
las que creo que se dio tan rápido es
porque mucha gente empezó a utilizarlas
porque fue masivo el uso de estas
tecnologías siempre que algo se hizo
masivo una tecnología que estaba por ahí
dando vueltas y se hizo masiva
pero un salto increíble y la gente
empezó a utilizarlas y formó parte de
nuestras vidas como sociedad
y hay una tecnología actualmente que
puede llegar a hacer lo mismo esta
tecnología de la que le vengo a hablar
les da la posibilidad a las computadoras
de vernos en profundidad si nos ven en
profundidad las computadoras y para que
trabajemos un poco este concepto de cómo
es eso de vernos con profundidad cómo es
una cámara de profundidad cómo es la
visión computacional cómo ha
evolucionado esto vamos a hacer un
ejercicio con cosas que nosotros
habitualmente estamos acostumbrados a
ver si o algo que no tenemos muy
integrado que es nuestro nuestra vista
nuestros ojos
nosotros podemos ver con profundidad si
algunos con mayor éxito otros con feroz
éxito pero podemos ver en profundidad y
para que podamos hacer un ejemplo de
esto cada uno tiene un un palito que les
entregaron la entrada si esto se va
hacer entre dos
las cámaras las cámaras que normalmente
son cámaras que veían en colores ahora a
partir del 2010 pueden ver en
profundidad pueden lograr detectar esa
profundidad aparte de ver en colores tal
cual como hacen nuestros ojos si todos
los palitos arriba a esta excelente
bueno muy bien no eran palillos para
después de comer sino que eran para
hacer esta intervención en este momento
lo que vamos a hacer son de a dos
personas de esta intervención va a ser
de tres pasos si el primer paso una
persona va a ser el asistente y el otro
va a ser el que va a jugar con esto así
que unos miren se conozcan se y vean
cuál va a ser el asistente igual no y a
partir de ese momento los tres pasos van
a consistir en lo siguiente el primer
paso va a ser que el asistente va a
dejar quieto el palito y la otra persona
va a intentar colocar la punta del otro
palito encima sí
si el asistente lo tiene y la otra
persona intenta colocar el palito encima
sí
presta la atención en la dificultad que
van a tener si cuando hagan este
ejercicio
el siguiente paso al paso 2 va a ser
taparse un ojo intentar hacer lo mismo y
el paso 3 taparse el otro ojo e intentar
hacer lo mismo mientras en este
ejercicio lo importante que ustedes sean
conscientes conscientes del nivel de
dificultad que tienen para hacer esta
actividad si bueno vamos a empezar lo
que ya se adelantaron 1 y drama ahora
vamos a empezar todos concéntrense un
asistente el otro con los ojos abiertos
colocan un palito arriba del otro con un
solo ojo intentan colocar un palito
arriba del otro cambian de ojo e
intentar hacer lo mismo
qué le sucedió
qué le sucedió a los que estaban
tratando de hacer esta actividad si a la
mayoría les fue muy difícil hacer esto
con un solo ojo
porque porque nuestra visión está
acostumbrada a necesitar de los dos ojos
para calcular la profundidad o sea
nuestra vista necesita de los dos ojos
para poder calcular la profundidad con
la que estamos viendo si a los que les
resultó igual de difícil con los ojos
abiertos que con un ojo y con el otro
les comento que forman parte del 12% de
la población que tienen problemas para
ver con profundidad
por eso vinieron auxiliado a las
computadoras las computadoras desde 2010
gracias a una compañía que desarrolló
desarrollada consolas para videojuegos
nos pueden ver en profundidad y pueden
detectar aparte de los colores como
detecta a nuestros ojos también la
profundidad como detecta a nuestros ojos
y eso es algo grandioso saben por qué
porque genera un mundo de aplicaciones
novedosas una revolución de cosas se
pueden hacer ahora a partir de esto y se
va a generar un mundo de cambios por
ejemplo vamos al área de salud en el
área de salud si uno empieza a hacer un
ejercicio de rehabilitación por ejemplo
algo que es aburridísimo si van a un
kinesiólogo bar ya les va a decir que
hagan un movimiento y lo repitan varias
veces qué pasa
fíjense en la pantalla de atrás yo tengo
una cámara de profundidad si ven como me
sigue ahora voy a mover el brazo y puedo
juzgar a que estoy moviendo un brazo no
sólo puedo tener esta interacción atrás
sino que puedo estar reventando globitos
o haciendo algo mucho más divertido que
mover el brazo pero cuando yo estoy
moviendo este brazo le estoy dando mucho
informe
la cámara de profundidad y sabe mi
ángulo que estoy logrando mi velocidad
mi aceleración y a partir de eso podemos
generar una herramienta poderosa para
los profesionales y divertida para el
usuario
eso en el área de la salud ahora si
vamos a cualquier otra área por ejemplo
el arte en el área del arte una persona
podría ser una intervención un artista y
podría moverse dentro del escenario y
generar interacciones que son muy
divertidas ahora no voy a mujer fuera
del círculo rojo así pero imagínense que
podría ser así y disparar luces para un
lado o disparar luces para el otro o
generar música tocando un piano virtual
si no me dejaron el otro por suerte
porque se ha sido mucho más difícil
porque lo mío es esto de la tecnología
he sido testigo de un montón de cambios
he sido testigo de revoluciones que se
han dado continuamente y ahora este tipo
de tecnologías son una revolución en sí
misma son una revolución porque nos van
a permitir a nosotros ya las máquinas
vernos de otra forma vernos cómo nos ven
nuestros mismos ojos
puede llegar a cambiar cosas incluso en
el área del marketing por ejemplo en el
área del marketing nosotros podríamos
hacer vidrieras que respondan a las
personas que están paradas enfrente como
ven mi cara ahora yo puedo saber punto a
punto y el sabiendo generando
información sobre mi cara y a partir de
eso podría saber algún tipo de estado
emocional que tenga yo o sea es
característico que la persona que está
feliz tiene una sonrisa de lado a lado
dicen sí y eso lo puedo detectar con la
computadora por otro lado también puedo
saber si estoy un poco triste hay un
montón de reacciones que genera el
cuerpo humano y hay un lenguaje que es
universal que es el lenguaje físico y
eso nos puede dar información sobre el
comportamiento de las personas porque
esto me está trayendo todo el cuerpo y
aparte el rostro puedo generar cosas que
reaccionen a mi estado de ánimo entonces
podría llegar a mi casa si estoy un poco
triste y tener colores que empiezan un
poco te no es todo después me van
transmitiendo alegría poco a poco o si
vengo para arriba muy alegre mantener
esa alegría cuando entro a mi casa así
que todas las luces se prendan y genera
una experiencia nueva para mí todo esto
se puede lograr es una nueva revolución
que se está dando esta misma cámara que
yo tengo acá
se está generando en celulares también
se está generando en dispositivos que
son portátiles y que pueden ser una
revolución en sí misma por eso para mí
que vengo de la parte tecnológica es muy
importante estar aquí hoy con ese
objetivo con el objetivo principal de
decirles que estén atentos que hay
cambios que se están dando que hay
revoluciones que están pasando en este
momento que esta es una de ellas y que
pueden ser espectadores como lo fue toda
mi vida o pasar a ser protagonistas como
lo estoy diciendo ahora muchas gracias
[Aplausos]